okay this is super interesting
there are hundreds of cases against
alleged trump rioters from january 6th
right now hundreds of cases
um
there has now been a decision by the
judge in the case to release the police
interrogation video of one of the
accused writers a a man named danny
rodriguez danny rodriguez many in my
audience thought this was like a kid
like barely an adult i did too turns out
it's a 38 year old man danny rodriguez
has admitted to being the individual who
tased
officer michael fanon who was one of the
three or four officers who testified
before the committee investigating the
january 6th riots we're going to look at
some clips of the police interviews uh
some call them interrogations and
they're interesting in a number of ways
in terms of the police interviewing
techniques they are all completely
standard when i streamed some of these
clips yesterday there were people in the
chat saying
everything here is crazy that the police
are doing and others saying this is all
totally standard everything that happens
here is completely standard it doesn't
mean we like all of it but it is all
completely standard let's jump in here
is when he is first read his miranda
rights and danny rodriguez says you know
i'm always told i'm not supposed to talk
i want to talk to you guys in
the past lawyers have always told me you
know you don't say anything
we're not gonna help you
well look by signing this
you're just acknowledging that you read
your rights and that you're willing to
talk to us at this time just because you
signed it doesn't mean any of these
rights go away these rights are always
with you throughout the entire process
that you're in the legal system okay
does that make sense all right so
totally standard danny signs
acknowledges that he's been read his
rights and then does proceed to talk
although he seems sort of hesitant in
this next moment the officers do
something that's very very typical
and i'm not saying this is good or bad
it's very very typical they say listen
we want your side of the story because
right now we're getting everybody else's
side
and we want your side of the story the
implication is always that you can help
yourself by telling your side of the
story now
defense lawyers will tell you
it's never in your interest to just
start talking in this way
um you really want to make them have to
prove their case against you now this
guy ultimately admits what he did and
there's video evidence and whatever but
just merely you know for people saying
oh well he's being trick this is typical
we want to hear your side of the story
every defense attorney i know would say
get a lawyer don't say a word and get a
lawyer this is an opportunity here for
you to
let us know and help us understand
because right now we don't we don't
frankly understand
exactly what happened from your
perspective right and
i think that
there's an opportunity here for us to
get clarity on what what went down and
what you and these are always the terms
that
investigators use
this is an opportunity for you most
people hear opportunity that that sounds
good
uh we can get we can clear this up let's
clear this up and uh
good police interviewers already have
the clarity they need from evidence and
other people they've spoken to and what
they mean by clarity is getting you to
admit that this is the thing uh that you
did so then they get on to some pretty
interesting
substantive stuff
substantive stuff why did danny
rodriguez start going to rallies in the
first place trump rallies and other
right-wing rallies well among other
things it was alex jones and infowars uh
take a listen to this
and and so
i think that's kind of what
what i'm trying to like understand
i don't know what happened either
is i want to know that danny though
i want to know
i want to know that danny that
you know that kind of intervened in that
situation and i want to know how that
danny got
to
january 6.
um
your story is an important story
i just think that
um
and by the way that line your story is
an important story i got a couple of
emails from defense lawyers who said
without saying anything about this
particular guy
oftentimes
people in these situations
don't
really
understand what's going on and that the
detectives are there only if they
believe you did it um to be able to
build that case against you to
ultimately have this go to trial and get
a conviction
this idea of your story is an important
story
more sophisticated individuals i mean
listen if i was sitting there i would go
stop blowing smoke or you know you know
where
an important story what do you do i look
like an idiot to you an important i mean
it's just it's an it's but it works and
that's why they say stuff like this is
an important story i seem crazy you're
like a conspiracy theorist because you
guys are it's gonna come out and i'm
gonna get locked up because like i
believe this and it's gonna put me in
jail
okay
um so continuing to
uh
ask those questions and um he does for
the most part uh
continue talking about it and then they
get to this part about uh alex jones
let's take a listen to that we've done
this for a long time we've talked to
like i told you we talked to a lot of
people
and a lot of people
are worried about being judged when they
talk to law enforcement that we're going
to have an opinion
and i'm telling you right now
we don't we don't hold judgment over you
we want we could be the jury in the
judge
even even as
a fellow human being right
that's what we're telling you we're
looking at you today as a as a fellow
human as a fellow citizen of this
country as somebody who has lived here
and put an investment into this country
of your your work and
your
you grew up here and
look i don't have any loyalty to any
other country such as america and this
is all i know and this is all i want
and i don't care about
any other part of the world except for
our team
so how how did the danny
that
stood
on the line in between law enforcement
and antiqua blm how did you get get to
that point what happened in your life
like
how did you start going to these rallies
um
you have fours and just infowars so like
alex jones stuff
yeah okay
alex jones and infowars is what started
to radicalize him
in this direction now maybe the most
contentious aspect of this
is that his lawyers are now claiming
he signaled he didn't want to talk
by shaking his head at one point during
the interview and i'm going to show that
to you and this is pretty early on
um and so his lawyer
is asking that everything including the
eventual confession i'm going to play
for you be thrown out now i'm going to
play the video for you where he shakes
his head he absolutely shakes his head
very slightly
and then
he does continue talking i'm going to
tell you in a moment the case that his
lawyers are making if you're watching
it's all i've had to watch it 10 times
to even see this he very very slightly
shakes his head here okay so let's pay
very close attention and see if you can
spot it
you want to talk about that
okay so he's asked do you want to talk
about that it's a very very slight head
shake very very slight i'll play it one
more time it's barely visible
you want to talk about that
because i tell you what
everybody else is going to talk about
that yeah i'm pretty ashamed
so what happens is he's asked do you
want to talk about that it's a very
slight head shake and then he's told
everyone else is going to talk about it
and then he says well i'm ashamed and
then he continues talking
it's incredibly subtle the argument that
his lawyers are making is everything
after that is inadmissible because when
a
suspect
says they don't want to talk
they can resume talking under their own
choice
but they have to be the ones doing it
and this is the argument his lawyers are
making and because the detective then
said well everyone else is going to talk
about it
the lawyers are saying that is
continuing to question him even though
it's not literally a question that they
continued even though he shook his head
this i spoke to a couple defense lawyers
they
they're saying this is very very
50 50.
um but that if they had to guess
this is not going to be a confession
that is thrown out on the basis of that
slight head shake but that's what his
lawyers are arguing for now then you get
to a key moment which is where he says
yes i tased him he tased officer fanon
this is sort of like the key moment of
the confession okay
what do you want me to tell you that i i
taste them yes explain explain
yes why did you taste him i don't know
i'm a piece of
i'm sorry i don't know he's that he's a
human being with children
and he's he's he's not a bad guy he
sounds like he's just doing his job and
so here it starts to sound like there's
some aspect of remorse i'll get back to
that here he says he was in dc because
as far as he knew trump called them to
dc
how do you get to
january 6 like how what's what else
happens in that period of time
some problems trump called this business
tell me about that
how did he let you guys know to come to
dc
if he's the commander-in-chief and the
leader of our country and he's calling
for help
he thought he was calling for help
i thought he was
i thought we were doing the right thing
so we were just
i had no plans of what was gonna happen
i didn't know what was gonna happen so
he believed trump was calling them he
believed trump was calling him and then
it did get emotionally escalated and
there was kind of this kind of breakdown
feel to it danny did you feel like you
were
the three percent
here like like
like those people
that
stormed the capital that
those were patriots those were people
who were doing that because they were
the three percent that were going to
free our country from
fraudulent
politicians and schemes
of evil people so that way we could
have a
republic that was going to be whole
again is that what you thought
you thought you were that three percent
guy
i know man i know it's okay
i'm sorry guys no we know look look
listen
we know you thought that you were that
three percent guy i'm so sorry i did so
this is interesting for a number of
different reasons one this is just one
story of the hundreds there are hundreds
of people like this who they believed
that they were patriots they believed
trump was calling them to dc they
believed they were doing the right thing
by tasering or tasing a police officer
and on and on and on number two in
moments he sort of seems remorseful
but then in other moments you realize he
actually isn't he talks about he and his
patriots is there going to be room in
the jail for how the number of patriots
that are there
he uh still continues to insist that
they were doing generally speaking the
right thing
so what this one story tells us i don't
know but understand that when we say
stochastic terrorism people see these
messages all this different stuff and it
leads to real world action
it very much does and every single one
of them now is a case involving
investigators the judicial system etc
and the people who incited this stuff at
least so far have suffered no
consequences whatsoever we're going to
follow this case and others as they go
forward one of our sponsors is called
privacy privacy is a totally free
service that i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video